so that is what we call pruning
engineering work that is the multikill
most critical process during a sensors
development we pick up we with peek at
those we amplify those genes which
encode the gpcrs from our human genome
from our human DNA's we clone those that
use a technology called PCR polymerase
chain reaction we got the DNA encoding
those gpcr and then we can use some
enzymes to split it into like 2 or 3
different segments and then you got some
slot to dude and and you can do you like
you got like one slot if you cut it you
cut it this way you got one slot and
then I clumb we clone the fluorescent
protein from a jellyfish yes from
Jellyfish the green fluorescent proteins
from the jellyfish the red fluorescent
proteins from the coral so we clone the
fluorescent protein from the coral or
from the jellyfish and we got the
diamond fragment and we insert the teeny
fragment into the GPCR slot and that
this repart comes together was sealed by
some enzymes and the way in this way we
got the whole DNA sequence for
neurotransmitter sensors actually you
cannot just do it that way and God a
very perfect sensor with cute expression
level with good fluorescence even with
your signal-to-noise ratio you need to
you need to engineer very carefully
where to insert the fluorescent protein
into that you can see our backbone
you need to also engineer the linkers
the the linker protein or DNA sequence
between them that will defines how
efficient how the efficient of the
so-called conformational change transfer
from GBC are to the fluorescent protein
there might be some linkers so you need
to tweet you need to do we call it
random notation to the Slinker sequence
to see which amino acid is the perfect
and after that we'll also engineer some
to some mutations within the gpcr we
call the the neurotransmitter is very
small that will bind with some specific
place within the GPCR we call the
binding pocket and within the binding
pocket DNA sequence were all amino acid
sequence will defines the affinity
between sensor or between cbcr ways
neurotransmitter
so we're also engineer some sort of a
specific site within the binding pocket
to god the perfect sensor ways with good
spatial temporal not 'no with fast
kinetics with goo signal-to-noise ratio
to transfer the chemical signal into
fluorescence signal and yes there is a
lot of work if you are a first-year
graduate student just started to use
such kind of we called protein
engineering you take like three days or
today and like three days to get such a
construct and the test of whether it
works or not and took us a perfect
sensor probably you need to try more
than 1000 alternatives to god a perfect
construct
and you need to that that is a lot of
work but but we we figure out some way
to do it paralleling so that can save
some time but it's still a lot of work
for a graduate student to got such a
perfect sensor and actually I am very
lucky when I join the lab we already got
those sensors some our prior student in
order I've already butyl sensors and
tested those two sensors the most simple
modal cultured cells artificial cultured
cells in the medium sales in the medium
we tested those sensors and where I know
that big works and what so so it turns
to me I I take the job to create
transgenic animals to test whether their
the sensors can whether there's this
sensor can be used for in vivo studies
in intact animals in the living brain
during specific behavior